tell me about it working on all the
different things you've got because
because of the multi-part question there
are so many different things and there's
also two different solutions and each
one has its own attendant set of details
and that's why I've brought up this
table okay and maybe your final users
will just show that when you're looking
back at your working and you see all
your answers sort of interspersed
throughout your your sort of lines of
solutions I'm gonna be able to see the
important parts really quickly okay
you'll relate to each other so let's
review we actually got most of the way
through the question well you guys got a
little bit confused about some angles
we'll revisit that in a second we found
two solutions for the tank what angle it
should fire at in order to hit the
targets okay and I think we've said that
the tiger was two kilometers away
horizontally and the mountain it was
sitting on as all good man targets are
was a clone at all okay so it's an
Australian announcement basically which
anywhere else in the world would we call
a hill that you know we have no maths to
angers well do you remember what were
the two angles good can you miss of one
which is 45 degrees or 10 units of three
that came from when you factorized video
equation we got alpha okay and I think
10 inverse of 3 was loose anyone good we
could do it 10 minutes but degrees is
enough just to illustrate what's going
on right so obviously the difference
between these is there's a much higher
angle and then there's a more shallow
angle both of them will be fine okay
now flight time what did we get since
this one is more direct it doesn't take
as long I think the answer we got was 10
root 2 which reaches that one point for
something right so I guess that would
make this 14 one seconds there about
yeah since option 2 it's going it's
traveling so much further through the
air they've got work that was 10 root 10
some eventually calculator
they'll quit six so more than twice as
long is how long it's in the air because
of the different variable alright now
here is where we stand to run that's
what we sort of left off we got half of
it here so we didn't quite get there so
in order to be a little clearer on okay
how exactly do work these two things now
what I want us to get is the six
equations six six equations that define
the motion of this projectile
okay you can think about them in three
levels first you're going to have your
acceleration horizontal and vertical and
that's the same for every predict our
motion question right
what's the horizontal acceleration zero
right
it gets fired and there's no there's no
like wind it's no air resistance it's
just gonna keep on going horizontally at
the same rate so that's going to be zero
what's its vertical acceleration the
only force acting on it is gravity so
you're gonna get minus G which we define
the discretion at this is ten okay now
from there we integrated to get the
velocity equations right you are X dot
and why don't
okay now X dot because there's no
acceleration right X starts going to be
a constant it's gonna be one day and
it's never gonna change because there's
no acceleration to actually make a
change right so do you remember what we
got first oh yeah good so when it comes
to x dot y dot right there gonna be
cosine and sine you remember cuz they're
alphabetical right and when you get a Y
dot what we can do great this you don't
just get a constant you also get this
part that integrates up right so we got
minus 10p plus the angular component 300
sign off okay
all right the last C which is really
quite simple to read off is that we
integrated one more time to get the
displacement equations x and y okay so
secondary first through B of the actual
original the primitive function this is
just a constant so when you integrated
you just stop at e on it
right of course we have with our
constant integration but using because
we set the arm
we set the tank to be at the origin
right so the cost that he was just here
oh yeah Sam deal with this you integrate
up and this minus 10t becomes minus 5 T
squared and of course this also attracts
a team as well okay now let's come back
and think about what we're doing when we
introduced this topic reset often you'll
get sorry start again you can define
something's angular momentum in terms of
two different ways you could have its
polar definition right which was angle
and speed V right or you could have you
could resolve the velocity and get its
horizontal and its vertical components
right so seeing as we're trying to find
a polar definition and we've got the
Cartesian definition already these are
the two equations we want to knock on
okay now we go a little bit confused
because we figure out that alpha alpha
is this this is the Alpha up here right
you might like alpha does not change
once you've solved it that values going
to stay the same for all of your
equations okay
so let's review how do we get impact
speed and impact angle just for this
first option okay well I'm going to need
to the horizontal and vertical velocity
so X time this is when I should write
when alpha is 45 okay just so I don't
confuse those two cases X is going to be
200 cos 45 cost 25 102 this is 200 over
2 so that's like hundred root two now Y
dot if you remember we also had a look
at this and because you've got your
minus 10t
at the front you had to work out okay
how long did it take so you need to
bring this 10 root two that's mighty you
need to bring that into your equation
right so why that's going to be
- ten times ten or two plus 200 sine 45
okay
now 200 plus 45 + 200 sine 45 are the
same so this is going to be M into root
2 but this part at the front that's -
algebra truth so what we got was 0 now
what does that mean well if we draw your
rectangles right you run into sort of a
young dilemma because you've got a
horizontal part to it right this is your
X dot which is 100 root 2 well when you
go to work out the height of the
rectangle it doesn't have any quite
right so it's like there you go there's
your whole body per component okay I
actually do write on the side here y
dash is equal to sorry y dot is equal to
zero this is my rectangle okay for the
sake of completeness now where do we get
impact speed an impact angle from okay
well usually your rectangle looks like
this next thought why not
where is impact speed it's this thing so
that's me it's the hypotenuse right and
where this angle come from it's on
missing right
but in our rectangle right your
hypotenuse is just going to be equal to
well it's like I strength this thing
down until the hypotenuse and that
bottom line it's not the same right so
in this case V is going to be sorry
that's a 100 root 2 okay another way you
can see that it's a little less direct
but if you remember our equation for V
squared okay V squared and from
Pythagoras is X dot squared plus y
squared right that's just zero and this
is imaginary so again you can see be 100
root 2 for the same deal because you'll
have cutting these years sorry you all
hypotenuse use nothing all right so
there's our velocity that's attached
hundred meters per second okay
impact angle again because our rectangle
has known up or down it's just going to
be zero okay but you can confirm that
again with our equation for ten feet up
ten feet are comes from rise over run
right rise why not on run edge start
okay which is here is zero over 102 so
if you got tan theta being 0 the
equation that solves that is zero okay
so there's our answer
thank you and what does that mean this
is the last part I drew on the diagram
that means we actually hit it level on
horizontally okay
all right there we go there's our
answers for this side now we look at tan
inverse of 3 and this kind of angle
remember what happens I think I can fit
in order one cat impacts paid me back
I'm going to do the same thing with X
dot and y dot okay but I actually am
gonna get a rectangle this time right
when I want it's not my god I'm gonna
need to know COS of alpha this and sine
of alpha right now we sort of wanted to
avoid using a calculator to evaluate
this okay so do you remember we drew
your triangle up and if alpha is tan
inverse of three okay so I slap a poder
tan is multi set elevation so that's why
we've got this 3 1 through 10 this is
ringing bells yeah okay all right let me
fast forward of them get after you use
this kind of triangle to work out your
cos 45 and your sine 45 your X dot
it's when you return it's not this
identification now you pause for a
minute and make sure you interpret what
these numbers mean X 20 or 10 mm okay so
it still going that way this Y dot is
negative what does that correspond to
well it's going up and then it's coming
down director your vertical velocity is
toward the ground check okay watch out
for your signs so now I'm going to use
this to work out V right so you get V
squared is this squared plus this
squared that's going to be 16,000 and
that's going to be for thousands I get
20,000 okay so once I take the square
root let's see here 100
yes
now that make sense that seem consistent
say deepak sweet okay you think about
that one for a second let's go through
the angle now tan theta okay
that's rise over run so that's this over
this right and you can see just looking
at the values of that right your Y dot
is double your X dot okay so it's this
divided by that I'm going to get minus
two so when you slap that into your
calculator take the tan inverse you get
I think sorry approximately I think it's
minus 63 that's my memory yeah yep good
okay now what does that correspond to
this is one of the handy times when the
negative actually is what we are after
because yes it's minus 63 because it's
going in the opposite direction positive
angles mean we're increasing negative
angles mean with decreasing but when you
talk about impact angle right
much like velocity we're just thinking
about it has a scalar right so I would
actually say